aujourd'hui un français par exemple émet
moins de co2 qu'un chinois qu'un
sud-africain bouquin mongols
les les coop ont quand même une utilité
médiatique dans la mesure où elle nous
rappelle l'état de l'urgence climatique
là où on peut se montrer sceptique c'est
qu'on n'a pas toujours l'impression que
les gouvernements ont pris la mesure des
technologies a déployé le plus
rapidement possible pour respecter les
accords de paris et pour limiter au
maximum le changement climatique
aujourd'hui encore il n'y a pas de
consensus malheureusement sur la manière
d'atteindre cet objectif le plus
efficacement possible une forme de
schizophrénie aujourd'hui de la part des
gouvernements mondiaux tous nous parle
de développement durable c'est très bien
en revanche peu d'entre eux mettre en
oeuvre les mesures effectives qui
permettrait justement à ce développement
durable d'advenir
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous avez ceux qui pensent qu'il faut
réduire drastiquement le niveau de
l'humanité qui en soit je crois est une
contradiction puisque quand même
rappeler les raisons pour lesquelles on
lutte contre le changement climatique on
ne le fait pas pour faire plaisir à gaya
on le fait au contraire pour assurer à
notre espèce le plus haut niveau de
prospérité possible le changement
climatique s'il n'est pas maîtrisé nous
expose à des risques matériels
potentiellement insupportable c'est la
raison pour laquelle le progrès
technique reste la voie la plus juste et
la plus sûre puisque on sait aujourd'hui
que les technologies les plus coûteuses
les plus crédibles pardon pour lutter
contre le changement climatique sont
aussi les plus coûteuses et donc ce sont
des technologies qui sont davantage
accessibles aux pays riches et c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette opposition
comme on entend régulièrement entre
environnement et développement
économique elle n'a aucun sens elle n'a
aucune logique quand vous êtes un
israélien et que vous avez le pouvoir de
dessaler l'eau de mer que vous avez les
moyens de mettre en place des systèmes
d'irrigation
développer des pratiques agronomiques
avancer bien vous êtes beaucoup moins
vulnérables aux épisodes de sécheresse
que lorsque vous appelez madagascar il
est vrai en revanche convaincu que pour
ce qui est de l'enjeu de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre les pays riches
sont en moyenne beaucoup plus polluant
que les pays pauvres encore qu'il n'y
ait aucun automatisme puisque
aujourd'hui un français par exemple émet
moins de co2 qu'un chinois quing sud
africains ucca mongol pas parce que la
mongolie serait plus riche que la france
et passe au contraire c'est un pays qui
a des technologies très rudimentaire
quand vous êtes un pays pauvre mais que
vous dépendez exclusivement du charbon
et d'énergie sales pour assouvir vos
besoins eh bien vous émettez parfois
plus de co2 qu'un pays riches comme la
france dont une grande partie du mythe
électrique et énergétique est assurée
par le nucléaire
[Rires]
parce que l'europe est précisément la
région qui a vu naître l'idéologie
écologiste l'écologie politique en fait
on ne comprend pas cette idéologie si on
ne réalise pas que sa spécificité ne
résident absolument pas dans la quête
d'un environnement sain puisque en
réalité cette quête elle est universelle
et trans partisane elle traverse même
des sociétés et le temps je ne connais
personne qui dans l'histoire se lever un
matin en disant j'aime la pollution
d'ailleurs dans mon livre je cite des
figures de l'antiquité comme horace ce
n'est qu'ils déjà leur époque dénonçait
les fumées toxiques qui empoisonnent
l'atmosphère de rome qui souillaient les
bâtiments donc voyez que ces problèmes
ne sont pas nouveaux et que leur
dénonciation n'est pas nouvelle là où
l'écologie politique en tant
qu'idéologie qui émergent en europe
véritablement après la seconde guerre
mondiale innove c'est dans sa manière de
poser le diagnostic et d'envisager les
solutions c'est à dire que l'écologie
politique et en toute chose c'est une
critique de la société industrielle
c'est une critique de la civilisation
moderne lorsque le marxisme domine l
imaginaire collectif de la gauche on
accusait le capitalisme de paupériser
les passants les masses européennes ont
commencé à s'enrichir on a commencé à
dire bah oui en fait le capitalisme
occidental
puise sa prospérité au détriment du
tiers-monde lorsque la mondialisation a
commencé à enrichir toute l'humanité là
c'est l'espèce humaine qu'on a accusé de
détruire
l'environnement tête imaginaire de la
nature qu'il faut absolument des livres
et de l'emprise humaine elle a aussi
davantage pour ses militants de se
recouper avec le rejet des sociétés
modernes bonjour
[Musique]